Bodies all over the ground, necks twisted,
faces contorted in terror. SCP-173 - not one,
but an army - scatters out through Site-19,
massacring researchers one broken neck at a time.
Pure chaos. How could this possibly have happened?
The strobing of the blood-red emergency lighting
was already fear-inducing enough. So was being
hidden under one of the tables in the mess hall,
trembling as the noise of alarms rang out
through the facility. But the thing about the
flickering lights scared SCP Foundation
Researcher Mira Smythe all the more,
were the few seconds of darkness that
came between each flash of red. If it
had been any other containment breach,
she probably wouldn’t have even noticed;
for in those few seconds, when the
warning light lit up only to cut out,
she couldn’t see a thing. And her not being able
to see made it easier for them to move around.
Mira had lost track of time since the alarms had
first sounded to mark the containment breach.
She’d tried to keep count of the minutes, but
the drumming of her heartbeat had thrown her
off. There was no way of knowing if it had been
hours, or only a few minutes since everything
went wrong. Of course, the SCP Foundation
had plenty of procedures and protocols in
place to prevent or respond to situations
like this. Yet, the emergency alarms kept
echoing through the corridors, lights plunging
the facility into darkness every few seconds
only to break it up with a brief flash of
red. It seemed to Mira, from her hiding spot,
that this breach had proven far too much the
Foundation’s extensive procedures to counteract.
Maybe it was all over already, she thought
after a few more seconds, or maybe minutes,
under the table. What if… they had gotten bored,
tired of slaughtering their way through Foundation
personnel and slunk back to their containment
chamber. That would’ve been simpler, far less
terrifying than the alternative, that came
creeping into Mira’s head in the form of her next
thought. What if she was the only one left alive,
the last member of site personnel still breathing,
just by some random a hundred to one chance?
And if that was the case, how long would it
take them to find her? How many even were there?
A new sound, just detectable below the alarms,
broke through her avalanche of anxious questions.
Footsteps, the noise of boots clomping against
the floor, clearly belonging to a human and
not one of them. Cautious as to which way her
gaze was directed, Mira poked her head out from
beneath the table, glancing around during the
few seconds where the red of the emergency lights
allowed her to see. The steps were getting closer,
and as they did, Researcher Smythe realized
something that made her fearful for her
fellow survivor. They were running away, and
there was no way they could do that while also
looking back at what was coming after them…
“Over here!” she hissed in a hushed tone at
the sight of a pair of legs
crossing a nearby corridor.
Their thick, standard-issue military boots seemed
to match those worn by the Foundation’s security
personnel. The officer passed by, only to stop
and tiptoe closer to the mess hall, having heard
Mira’s whispered call. With the red lights
blinking, it looked like every other step the
security officer took had been edited out, like
they were teleporting closer in the dark. Watching
intently from her hiding place, it reminded Mira
sickeningly of the things she was hiding from,
how they moved… and the worrying fact that she
couldn’t see one following the security officer.
“Hello?” called a man’s voice
as he entered the mess hall.
“Under the table,” Mira whispered. “If we hide,
we can still see them, but they can’t see us!”
“Hiding?” he replied. “No, we need something that
can revert these things back to the original. It
was so much easier to handle when there was just
one of them. Look, let’s make a break for it; I’m
gonna grab SCP-3108 and then get the lights back
on. If we can restore visibility, we might be able
to stand a fighting chance against these things.”
The officer was looking around the cafeteria,
trying to locate the source of Researcher
Smythe’s voice, eyes distracted. Then,
the intermittent flickering of red light
cut off again, plunging the entire mess
hall into near-pitch darkness again. At the
same time, there was the sound of something
heavy and stone scraping against the flooring.
It turned Mira’s stomach, and she immediately
covered her mouth. She had no idea if they could
hear her breathing. Could a creature of stone even
detect sound at all? While the lights were down
and the security guard's back was turned, a pair
of sculptures, built from concrete and rebar,
traces of spray paint over their stone skin,
appeared behind the officer at impossible speed.
There was a sickening crunch, followed by the
sound of something dropping to the floor
of the mess hall. As the emergency lights
flicked back on, Mira could see them, the two
copies of SCP-173, standing still next to the
table she was under, bathed in red light.
This nightmare had all begun as an otherwise
ordinary Friday for the SCP Foundation. Only a
few hours earlier, Mira had been brainstorming her
latest pitch for a series of experiments involving
SCP-914. Otherwise known as the Clockworks,
SCP-914 was a large machine comprised of various
cogs, gyros, and gears, of unknown origin. Its
function, however, had long been documented
and was of great interest to the Foundation.
Any object placed within SCP-914’s Input booth,
could be transformed, destroyed, or improved
depending on the Clockworks’ setting. ‘Rough’
would disintegrate a subject, ‘Coarse’ would
dismantle it to its base components, and ‘1:1’
would merely replace the objected with a similar,
almost identical one. Then, there were the ‘Fine’
and ‘Very Fine’ settings. The former would cause
SCP-914 to improve any item, and the latter is
capable of the same but with one key difference.
‘Very Fine’ would refine an object even more,
usually by giving it anomalous properties.
The Foundation higher-ups had permitted staff
to freely conduct tests using the Clockworks,
although approval was required and all data was
to be recorded. While many of the scientists at
the Foundation were fixed on the mysterious
origin of SCP-914, or the furthest extent of
its refinement capabilities, Mira had been
thinking about it in a far more practical
way. She wasn’t interested in the how or why
of SCP-914’s inner workings, nor who had built
it. Her experiments were born out of considering
better usages for the Clockworks. It was a machine
that could provide endless possibilities, and Mira
was determined to make to the fullest use of it in
order to solve actual real-world problems.
“Imagine, for a moment,” she announced,
reading off her cue cards as she practiced
pitching her experiment to the Foundation’s
Senior Researchers. “Imagine a world where
nobody ever gets sick, where human beings are
able to live long, healthy and prosperous lives.”
“Maybe dial back on the Star Trek,” her colleague
Research Assistant Jensen interjected.
“Really, that’s what you call constructive
criticism?” she retorted, before continuing. “If
we apply the transformative, refinement power
of SCP-914, that world could be the future
that awaits us. For example, I’m proposing
tests that involve placing man-made chemical
compounds like painkillers, heart medication,
and other potentially life-saving medicines
through the Clockworks’ refinement process.
I’m not suggesting we need to set it to ‘Very
Fine’ and create anomalous versions of these
things. But what if, even on the ‘Fine’ setting,
we’re able to improve the effectiveness of our
existing treatments for all kinds of afflictions?”
Jensen raised their hand, patiently waiting to
comment like a child in a classroom.
“What?”
“A few things,” they replied, lowering their
hand. “First off, some if not all ‘man-made’
medications include some kind of organic
component. The O5 Council have banned all –”
“Yes, I am fully aware of the Containment
Procedures,” Mira interrupted them. “That’s
exactly what I’m trying to convince the
Council, or hell even just Doctor Bright,
to let me step around. I genuinely
believe we could be doing so much more
with SCP-914, and I need them to see that.”
“Look, I’m not here to rain on your parade,
Smythe,” her assistant reassured. “I’m only
bringing up concerns that anyone will have about
this proposal. You talked about wanting to improve
our existing medical treatments, which is noble,
don’t get me wrong. But have you considered
the wider effect that might have? If you make
everyone on Earth more resistant or even immune
to everything, then diseases are going to evolve.
What if we end up with a form of super bacteria,
resistant to all forms of medication, even if that
medicine’s been refined in SCP-914? Trying to
save the world might just bring about its end.”
“I’ve thought about that, but if the Council
starts allowing for biological testing again,
then the solution is obvious: we use the
Clockworks to eradicate whatever germs or diseases
are able to develop after improving treatment
options,” Mira explained, then adding: “Besides,
that can’t be any more dangerous than what we’ve
been using SCP-914 for. I mean, enhancing other
SCPs? That’s a recipe for disaster!”
“Got to agree with you there,” Jensen
sighed. “Even without placing them in
the Clockworks, the Foundation’s been
way too cavalier with the dangerous ones.
Speaking of, you know what tonight is?”
Smythe replied with a confused look.
“Date night,” they stated.
Elsewhere in the facility, unknown to Researcher
Smythe at that time, one of the dangerous SCPs
Jenson had mentioned had been let out of
containment. This was a regular occurrence,
even if it was considered a little unorthodox to
some. In fact, the only reason that the O5 Council
so often turned a blind eye to it was because of
the researcher it involved: Doctor Alto Clef. It
seemed Clef had a certain fondness for SCP-173,
the Sculpture: a living statue constructed
from concrete and rebar that could travel at
impossible speeds whenever it was unobserved.
Most Friday nights, Clef would have romantic
candlelit dinners with SCP-173, putting a dress
and blonde wig on the Sculpture and treating
it like his beloved partner. The whole while,
watched by Doctor Clef and a group of
D Class acting as waiters and cooks,
SCP-173 would stand motionless while the
bizarre date went on late into the night.
It was no secret that the Sculpture
was a highly aggressive creature,
with a penchant for snapping the neck of the
nearest person the moment that they blinked.
However, it was only because of Doctor Clef’s
reputation and track record for the elimination
of anomalies that he was granted the special
privilege of wining and dining with SCP-173.
This time, though, part way through their
regularly scheduled date, Doctor Clef was
called away to deal with matters relating
to another anomaly he’d been charged with
‘decommissioning’. The pair of D Class waiting on
the doctor and his date were instructed to wait,
keeping a close eye on SCP-173, alerting
each other in case they needed to blink.
It was a hell of a gamble, a risk that could have
been avoided if the Sculpture had been transported
back to its secure containment chamber. But Doctor
Clef could be ‘persuasive’… that is to say, he
threatened both D Class waiters with a bludgeoning
from his ukulele if they didn’t do as he asked.
Both the D Class stared directly at the Sculpture,
each one feeling the anxious beads of sweat slowly
crawling down their foreheads, worried that
they’d both blink at the same time by accident.
They announced their need to refresh their eyes
every so often, alternating between being the
watcher and the one allowed to blink. All the
while, SCP-173 was motionless. Perhaps it was
patiently waiting for Doctor Clef to return… or
for one of the D Class watching it to slip up.
As if through some cruel twist of fate,
a fly began to buzz through the air,
drifting towards the D Class with their eyes
on SCP-173. It looped and darted around,
its wings making an annoying droning. One of
the waiters announced he needed to blink again,
and the other told him he was free to do
so while he kept watch over the Sculpture.
At the exact same moment that one man blinked,
the fly zipped its way towards the second D Class,
distracting him and drawing his gaze for little
more than a millisecond. That fly whizzing past
was the last thing he saw, as SCP-173 darted
forward. It moved with such incredible speed that
it was imperceptible, grabbing the nearby D Class
– the one who’d spotted the fly – and killing him
instantly before the other could even open his
eyes. When he did, SCP-173 had vanished from its
spot at the date night table, nowhere to be seen.
Before the remaining D Class could realize it
was behind him, SCP-173 had made
short work of its other observer.
It began zipping unseen through the corridors
of the SCP Foundation facility. Doctor Clef had
returned to his date only to find the two D Class
waiters dead, and SCP-173 missing. Immediately,
he had raised the alarm, meaning that research
staff were too busy fleeing to safety to pay
any attention to the Sculpture quickly making its
way through the site. Swept up in the evacuation,
half-deafened by alarms, in all the commotion,
Researcher Mira Smythe hadn’t even realized she’d
left the door to the Clockworks wide open.
Shuffling down a corridor with her fellow
researchers, the lights suddenly went
out. A few nearby screamed in panic at
having been unceremoniously thrust into the
dark. Mira blindly reached for Jensen’s hand,
only to hear the sounds of multiple heavy
concrete feet dragging along the floor. Suddenly,
the emergency lights blinked on. She turned
and, to her horror, saw SCP-173 with its stony
arms around Jensen’s neck, their face stricken
with sheer terror, tears in their eyes. But now,
Mira quickly realized, as the corridor was filled
with shrieks of fear from the other researchers…
that there was more than one Sculpture now.
Mira barely managed to escape with her life
in all the confusion, crawling out of the
low-lit corridor on her hands and knees while
the multiple new SCP-173 instances slaughtered
anyone that couldn’t see them. Since then,
she had been hiding, hearing the scraping steps
of the Sculptures traveling around the facility
unobserved. They had attacked the fuse boxes
first, as if in a calculated tactical move:
take out the lights, and suddenly
everyone found it much harder to see them.
Even through the fear, it was hard for Mira
not to blame herself for all the chaos. She
couldn’t remember whether she’d left the door
to SCP-914 open or not, but it hadn’t taken her
long to figure out that the Clockworks had
something to do with his madness. Somehow,
SCP-173 had made its way there, had been able
to operate the machinery while the Foundation
staff were distracted by their own evacuation.
Presumably, with SCP-914 set to ‘Very Fine’, the
Sculpture had been transformed into its ultimate,
refined form… or multiple forms, it seemed.
There was a veritable horde of SCP-173s running
amok through the facility. It made sense,
Mira reasoned, in some twisted, cruel anomalous
way. The Sculpture had only ever been a danger
when unobserved; the second anyone took
their eyes off it, so much as blinked,
it would strike. How does a machine like SCP-914
improve upon that? Easy, it gives the Sculpture
the power to replicate itself. Anyone can look at
multiple things at once, of course, but nobody can
look at everything simultaneously. Even if someone
was watching a pair, or three SCP-173s, one more
could easily slip up behind them for the kill…
Still hidden under the table, Mira’s eyes were
locked on the pair of Sculptures in the mess hall,
the body of the security officer out of focus in
her peripheral vision. She dared not look away,
frozen in sheer fear that the second she blinked,
they would lift up the table and find her. She
had been so overwhelmed, so paralyzed with her
terror that she had forgotten about the lights…
As the emergency lighting flickered again, the
Sculptures both moved, shifting across the mess
hall as the room when dark, only to stop in place
the second Mira could see them again. They hadn’t
gotten closer. In fact, both looked to be leaving.
The only thing keeping them here was… her. She was
watching them, and it had frozen them in place.
Their greatest strength, the imperceptible
movement speed of SCP-173, was offset by an
indisputable weakness of their anomalous biology;
they couldn’t stop someone from looking at them,
and couldn’t stop themselves becoming still,
solid concrete when they were being watched.
Mulling over her options, Mira decided to follow
through with the plan from the fallen security
guard, to retrieve SCP-3108 and try to undo what
the Clockworks had done. Slowly, she slipped out
from under the table, keeping both eyes on the
pair of Sculptures, keeping them lashed to one
spot as she gradually backed out of the mess hall.
The lights went out and plunged the area into
darkness again, and Researcher Smythe could
hear the heavy, concrete scraping of the two
Sculptures looking for her as she blindly made
her way through the facility. She managed to
evade the roaming stone creatures, resisting her
natural instinct to hide and looking directly at
any she encountered on the way, making sure to
stay out of their view. If she saw them, she’d
freeze them. If they saw her, they’d chase her.
Eventually, fishing SCP-3108 out of a containment
box, Mira held the ‘weapon’ in her hand. It was
a heavily modified Nerf gun, which she loaded
a foam dart into and pulled the plastic slide
back. The creatively named ‘Nerfing Gun’ had
almost the opposite effect to SCP-914; instead of
improving something, SCP-3108 turned whatever was
shot with it into an inferior equivalent object,
something worse than itself. It might just work.
Drawing the gun as she heard the sound of
scraping concrete getting nearer and nearer,
Mira turned the corner, coming face to face with
one of the Sculptures. She held the gun high,
closing the gap between them, making sure she
didn’t miss but wary she needed to fire before
the lights blinked off again. She squeezed the
plastic trigger, sending the foam dart shooting
out of the barrel of the Nerfing Gun. The flimsy
projectile collided with the SCP-173 instance,
bouncing off its head and landing on the floor.
For a split second, the lights dimmed again,
then came back on. Mira’s heart had lurched
in her chest, only to see that the Sculpture
hadn’t moved at all. She leaned closer to it,
blinking intentionally. It still didn’t move.
It was rooted to the ground, fixed. Just a statue,
rendered powerless by the Nerfing Gun. Excitedly,
Mira knelt down and scrabbled around on
the floor to retrieve the dart, just as
the emergency lighting flickered out again.
In her excitement, Mira was too focused on
reloading SCP-3108. That is, until she heard the
shuffling of concrete and rebar behind her. The
lights were still out, and she fumbled blindly for
the foam dart, as the noise got closer and closer.
Her fingertips brushed the projectile, knocking
it further away, when suddenly the lights came
back up. But as she reached for it, Researcher
Smythe felt a large, cold presence behind her,
something huge and heavy… and made of stone,
lingering at the very corner of her eye.
Before she could turn around and face it,
something grabbed Mira, and a sickening
snap rang out through the corridor…
Now go check out “SCP-096 VS. SCP-173”
and “SCP-173 ORIGIN STORY - HOW 173 GOT
TO SITE-19”? Just be careful not to blink…